hello and welcome to this
uh spectator alternative conference
event uh on britain's housing crisis and
tackling intergenerational
unfairness in the wake of covid19
i think lockdown made everyone acutely
aware
of people's housing situation uh you had
um older people older professionals
tending to open houses with gardens with
space and able to actually kind of find
some comfort in that
in their garden and their space that
they had one as young londoners
uh had on average 9.3 square meters of
personal space roughly the size of a
prison cell so lockdown really did feel
like
locked down to them so the question is
how do we solve this problem
how do we get more houses built
something this country has struggled to
do for decades now
i'm joined today one absolutely
fantastic panel to
discuss this we have kate henderson the
chief executive of the national housing
federation
uh bob blackman the tory mp for harrow
east
who's done amazing work on homelessness
and is also the secretary of the very
powerful 1922 committee
and by john myers who's the co-founder
of yinbi which stands for yes in my
backyard the opposite
of nimby's now the way we're going to do
this
is kate and bob and john are all going
to speak for a couple of few minutes at
the beginning
and then i'm going to throw it open then
we'll have a bit of a discussion with
the panel and then we're going to throw
it open to your questions
uh so kate do you want to take us away
brilliant thank you jameson good morning
everybody
so i run an organization called the
national housing federation
we're the voice of housing associations
in england
our members manage um and own around
two and a half million properties
providing homes to around six million
people in england
as james said the pandemic has really
revealed the inequality in
in housing in britain and for many of us
our homes have been our place of work
they've been our place of homeschooling
they've been
our sanctuaries and as james said for
others it has simply been like living
in a prison and for at the really sharp
end of the housing crisis
actually having no home at all we did
some research
um a couple months ago looking at
people's housing conditions during the
height of lockdown
and our survey found that nearly one in
three people
experienced either mental or physical
health problems because of their housing
conditions
if you look at the english housing
survey you can see that a record
3.7 million people are living in
overcrowded homes
including 1.6 million children and by
overcrowding you know
this isn't just kids sharing a bedroom
it's children sharing bedrooms with
parents parents sleeping in bathrooms
and hallways and kitchens
homes are simply too small to meet their
needs
we know that 30 000 people spent
lockdown
in a single room as their home and what
that must have felt
like and we have over 62 000 families in
temporary accommodation so we have a
huge housing crisis and i think these
statistics really reveal the
pressures on individuals and on families
during knock down
and really highlight the need to have
investments
in social housing and why investment in
social housing and why
now because we are in a recession
we are seeing housing starts fall and we
are seeing the need
for safe secure affordable housing great
if we invest in social housing now
it would boost the economy it would
sustain thousands of jobs it would
support supply chains
and it would provide homes for for
millions of people
who need them so that's my opening
gambit and i'm very much looking forward
to the discussion
okay thank you so much bob do you want
to uh do you want to chip in
yes indeed thank you james and thank you
kate for that
introduction i think the reality is that
in this country we haven't built enough
housing for
30 years and uh the estimates are that
we need to build
300 000 new homes every year just to
to actually catch up um and certainly
we're going to need to do that for the
next
five years at the same time planning
permission has been granted for more
than a million homes
in this country that are unbuilt so we
have
those three four years of potential
development already in the pipeline
the big concern is they're not being
built so we have to remove the barriers
to actually building them i think the
other issue which we're covering
obviously during lockdown is
the number of people that have been
either required to work from home
or have chosen to work from home during
this
pandemic and we have to think of the
design of homes as well
so the first thing is you know if you're
one person
living in a one-bedroom flat you've
probably got space in which to work
but if there's a couple of you and
you're both working from home what's the
impact of that
and more importantly probably if you're
a family where do the kids
do their homework and so on so one of
the things that we have to
i think adjust our thinking now is that
in the new normal
more people will work from home more
often
that doesn't mean to say people will
work from home permanently and never go
into a place of work
but those that can work from home i
think are far more likely
to be able to work from home because of
the new technology
the other point that i would just make
about how we get more homes built
is the public sector have got to stop
selling land with respect to developers
what we've got to do is use that public
land to develop the housing
the social housing as kate says from i i
take the view of 100 000 units
a year for the next five years so there
are
so affordable homes that people can
choose to rent
and to part by so we we would have
if i was in a position to set this
policy i would say
we build those homes you can exercise
the right to
a shared ownership on day one but if
you don't do that you'll have a
guaranteed price
that you can buy that home over the next
five years
um and exercise that option any one time
all those proceeds from the sale of
those homes should then go into
the building of new social rented
accommodation now the beauty of this is
it would lead to a position
of providing the housing that we need it
would make the housing affordable
for people rather than having to rely on
benefits
because i think that's one of the big
challenges that we've seen that people
just
particularly during this lockdown have
really struggled in order to
to pay their rent and pay their way
i think that's that that's the key for
me the price of land
is so expensive now it's holding back
the development of new housing
thank you so much bob john over to you
so um our yinbi campaigns are pushing
for plentiful
well-designed homes with the support of
local people and this country has the
best housing heritage in the world
centuries of stunning buildings but
we've let down the ambitions of our
predecessors
as bob says since the second world war
we've never grown the housing stock at
the rate we did in the 1830s
never mind the 1930s and so as a result
most young people have given up on the
chance of ever owning a home
the the eminent economic historian
professor nicholas crafts estimated we
could boost gdp
by literally 20 percent and so overtake
germany in value-added per head just by
building the right kinds of homes in the
right
places but for decades we've built
mainly poorly designed homes nowhere
near enough of them
within reach of jobs people want to take
with high wage firms who want to hire
and bad planning
has led to horrible regional imbalances
and lack of opportunity not to mention
of course poor housing
now the government's planning white
paper aims to fix all that while making
the planning system more predictable
and the devil's in the details but for
me the most exciting idea in the white
paper
was reviewed on the spectators website
last month and it's an idea we've been
pushing for some time
to let residents of a single street
decide for themselves
what designs of additional development
to permit
so in some cases a street of drab 1950s
bungalows might jointly decide
to give permission for beautiful
terraced houses or stunning mansion
blocks instead
adding many more homes and making each
of those homeowners an overnight
millionaire
and that idea has been supported by
people including the royal town planning
institute
nicholas boyce smith of create streets
jacob rees-mogg
and the late sir roger scrutin that
reform has the potential to allow
millions more homes where needed
without touching the countryside while
improving those streets
making the homeowners happier and
boosting growth and that would
finally let us give all young people a
fair chance of good jobs
and the homes they need thank you thank
you very much
bob if i can start with you so what
you're essentially talking about it is
direct commissioning
yes i am yeah i mean i think the problem
is
that what five six years ago
there was a deliberate decision by
george osborne
and david cameron to divert housing
money
into building housing for first-time
buyers now we need to do that as well
don't get me wrong
but it meant that the social housing
program was basically decimated
and what we also know is unfortunately
this leads to
a a of an unvirtuous
cycle whereby basically
the public land is sold for private
development private delivers come in
they sell the land on and on and on and
eventually something gets built
and then they say ah we can't build the
social housing that was part of the
original planning permission so we have
to build it for
uh for profit people can't afford to buy
those properties
so private developers can't buy the
properties
then rent them out the people that move
in can't afford the rents
so they then claim housing benefit so
that actually we end up
subsidizing people uh people's rents
it's far better in my view
to have rents that people can afford to
pay from their pay packets
rather than subsidizing housing in the
way that we've chosen to do so
the other benefit of course of doing it
this way is i'm only talking about on
public land by the way
so it's publicly owned land already the
benefit of doing that
is that we will get direct commissioning
and far faster
development of the housing we're not in
a position whereby
we can afford the private sector i'm
afraid to develop the housing that we
need
because they will undoubtedly ration
supply
to maximize profits and i don't blame
them because they're private companies
but we we can't afford for this country
to continue on this basis
so yeah the oligopoly of housing
developers just they they want to just
drip things onto the market
rather than do anything that might
actually reduce the price um kate
where do you stand on that as an idea
so i think that that bob's idea of using
public sector land
to deliver a social good which is social
housing
makes a huge amount of sense and what
bob was saying is actually diverting
money away from from the housing benefit
bill but into rents that are actually
genuinely affordable so
a social rent is is typically 50 of a
market rent
down to about 30 in london and maybe up
to 60 in in the northeast
um but it isn't just that it's the
stability it offers
so that you know if you're a child right
now living in overcrowding or in the
private rented sector or worse than
temporary accommodation your
education your health your life chances
are so impacted by not having that
stability
um as as well as you know the
affordability side of things
and so i would fully support the use of
public sector land
to to deliver um social housing and that
isn't to say also that we don't fully
support
routes into home ownership we do it's
just how do we get best value
for for the economy and for society out
of the public good which is
is that public land john i i think a few
months ago
i would agree with almost everything you
said but i
wonder whether there's an element that
this current crisis has
shifted things which is if we're now in
a world of of you know if we
if you can have conference fringe events
on zoom you can do most things on zoom
um but people aren't aren't as wedded to
having to live uh near big urban centers
as they once were
but there is now more of a chance to say
you know i mean
classically the problem in this country
has been as the the government is
finding with its algorithm for
determining housing need
is that when you try and work out where
you need to build more houses it tends
to be
london and the southeast uh rather than
uh the rest of the country but is there
not a case now
that with so much of life moving online
with people maybe going to the office
kind of once a week rather than every
day
but there is actually an opportunity to
say look people would actually
rather live in in uh some of the uh
in some of these towns that have had not
had a great time in the last 20 30 years
and there is a chance to kind of
regenerate them rather than simply try
to
build
more houses in the southeast so it's a
great point and
um i certainly agree that the the
pandemic has caused a step
change in adoption of these sorts of
technologies video conferencing
and people are not probably going to be
going into the office as in as
as much as they did before but i'm not
sure they'll just be going in one day a
week in many cases you might see a 20 or
a 40
reduction in office usage but i think
most people will still be going to the
office
i'm happy to bet in two years time the
spectator will still have
the attending physical party conferences
um
so i'll be interested to hear you take
that bet and so i don't think i don't
think distance is going away
um and so i think the critical question
is how do we best help the sorts of
places you've talked about
and actually unfortunately the planning
system has hurt them because
if you ban offices um and housing where
the jobs are
essentially you create a sorting effect
and um
let me take a take an example after the
black death in 1348
the aristocracy went to the king and
said we don't want
the laborers moving around in this
newfound shortage of labor because
they're going to demand higher wages and
so
so the king actually banned labour is
moving around the countries the statute
of laborers
and that's unfortunately what we've done
by planning and it's kept wages
artificially low
in many of these regions uh bob to move
back from
uh 1348 to the present day um
when you look at the uh trouble that is
being caused by this
uh planning algorithm among some of your
colleagues
yeah it it it slightly makes one despair
doesn't it because
the simple basis of the formula is that
you need to build
the most houses where housing is least
affordable compared to wages
but that seems to bring out a lot of
your colleagues in hives um i mean are
we ever going to build enough houses if
that remains the case
well i think yeah i think whenever you
construct an algorithm to determine
how things are going to work there are a
number of factors that go into that
algorithm
as you quite rightly say what is being
determined at the moment is
the areas with the most expensive
housing have to take
the most uh property development i think
the big
problem that we've got with these
proposals
uh is that the some of the uh areas for
example in london
um just to give you an example a barnett
the borough of barnet and i don't have
any
connection with the borough party i used
to add i've been told
they've been the most successful
developers of
new housing in london and they've been
told to treble the amount that they will
will have to build
i mean what that means is that there's
only one place to go and that's upwards
in terms of tower blocks now that
actually then leads to the destruction
of suburbia
as we know it and so i think our problem
is not so much
um this algorithm is understanding that
things have changed because of this
pandemic as you quite rightly say
people can choose to live and if they
want to
probably on an island in scotland uh if
they want to and
still be able to work in london because
of the
of the the fact that they could work
from home so people can choose now to
work from home
and they may choose and this this is
something we need to consider now
they may choose to commute far longer
distances
for the one or two days a week that they
come into an office
as opposed to the daily grind of having
to travel every single day
i think this is something that is going
to be important equally
the other challenge i think we we have
is that in our towns and cities
because i predict there'll be less of a
demand for
office space and traditional workspace
actually with appropriate controls
we can change those offices we've got
many homes that have been converted into
offices particularly in london
why not convert them back to homes where
people can live in them
and we can repopulate our towns and
cities
and then people will be able to walk to
work as a per which
always used to be the case okay well
where do you stand on that this idea of
of you know
if if um the banks are all gonna require
less office space you know why not turn
some of those big tower blocks in canary
wharf into homes well where are you on
that question
so i think converting uh
office buildings into homes or former
other types of commercial premises
and can be a really good sustainable
thing to do
depending on how you do it so it can be
perfectly sustainable to look at a
building and think
you know what what should its future use
be and we've seen that with
religious buildings with theaters with
office buildings and but it's it's how
you do it and the quality of what you
end up with
and at the moment we have a policy
called permitted development
where you can convert commercial
buildings into residential
with a prior approval process but
without a full planning permission and
we've got some real concerns about that
because of of some of the quality of the
homes that's being created in terms of
space
lack of access to windows um and some
really basic things
that haven't been considered like where
will children play if they're going
straight out onto a street or how do
they get to school or is that public
transport
that kind of thing um so if we are going
to be thinking about the future of our
high streets and our inner city areas
and buildings where perhaps there are
less people going into work and
converting them
let's not do that outside of planning
let's do that in a really creative
way that creates high quality
environments and ensures that that
people have a say over what's in there
that we get a good social mix
that you get a proportion of affordable
housing all of those things are not
possible
with permitted development so yes
changing use of buildings can be great
but not outside of planning through you
seem to be more skeptical than the other
panelists that this pandemic is going to
lead to lasting change i get the
impression that you think
as soon as there's a vaccine or some
kind of mass spit testing program
we'll be back to um the way we always
were uh
and life will return to kind of
pre-covered levels pretty quickly
am i am i accurately summarizing your
view here not quite i mean
i'm not certainly not saying we'll go
back to the way things are there's been
a step change people spend a lot of
money
and time getting used to new technology
we have an airline pilot on our panel
right now who's an expert in in all of
this
um and so there's definitely been an
acceleration of the trend that we saw to
people working more away from the office
but i don't think the office is dead um
people you know people get tired of zoom
conferences they want to be able to
shake hands with people they
they want to catch the nuances that you
get from face to face
and so with the technology just isn't
there yet to abolish distance it might
be one day but i'm afraid it's not quite
there yet
brilliant well we've got some very
interesting questions coming in i'm
going to start with one from
miles saying that the ew s1 cladding
scandal is holding up everything
uh even on safelaps this is the
requirement for a
post-grantful tower and that awful fire
but for buildings to be certified safe
and for any unsafe cladding to be
removed
how can we break this bureaucratic
deadlock um bob do you want to tackle
that one
yes thanks james um we uh i i sit on the
housing communities
and local government select committee uh
we are doing at the moment free
legislative scrutiny on the draft safety
bill
um and and we are i'm afraid every week
discovering more aspects of this i mean
i
this this current position over
certification of properties being safe
is
is i'm afraid the tip of an iceberg
we do have a problem about the number of
qualified people in this country
to actually go around do the inspections
uh do the surveys and then
sign off uh something as safe we also
have
a huge backlog in the um wake of
uh grenfell of unsafe cladding and it's
not just
acm cladding it's also these other types
of cladding as well
that have been put on buildings um
signed off under existing building
regulations
uh and then now um they've just been
discovered to be
unsafe and one of the problems is that
the testing regime
that we have for cladding and other
purposes is not fit for purpose
and has got to be changed and it's going
to be made much more transparent
and obvious to people so how do we break
that log jam well
for a start we've got to get more people
qualified to be able to do this job
of going around signing them off because
i feel really sorry for
any leaseholders in these properties
because at the moment
basically they will not be able to sell
their property their property is
probably
worthless um as a result of this
position uh
we've got to urgently get people up to
speed
in order to get this done there's there
i'm afraid
there isn't a quick fix on this
particular issue and that's one of the
problems
but i think everyone deserves to know
that they are living in a safe building
because at the moment
the backlog on removing cladding is far
too great
fixing this problem has been far too
slow
and to be fair the government has
allocated the money
to start doing this it's actually
getting the money spent is the biggest
problem at the moment
uh within the industry and providing uh
the the safe cladding that that everyone
needs
because there's there's a reason for
having cladding in the first place
okay do you want to comment on this
um yes please i think um agree with
everything bob's just
said and the safety of residents has got
to be the number one
priority it's a huge priority for us and
our
members specifically on the ews one
issue which is the external wall system
certification
issue only the government has the power
to unstick this
this this is a um this is a situation
where
we are um doing work as fast as we
possibly can um
but we have not got access to enough
um experts to do the work but also those
forms are now being required on
buildings
that are not high-rise buildings we've
even heard them being required
from some mortgage lenders on on you
know brick buildings townhouses which
which don't require them so we need the
government um to act
really quickly on this to resolve this
um
but it is broader than so that's an
immediate issue with kind of unsticking
those building
up you know the mortgage market actually
have people remortgaging people trying
to sell
and huge numbers of people and you'll
see it day in and day out in the press
now of
of people trapped in flats unable to
move to their to their next home and
also people unable to buy
um there is also a wider building safety
program as bob has said so it's not just
about those forms it's a much bigger
issue and we do need the government to
lead a coordinated
building safety program and that must
mean prioritizing those buildings that
are highest risk
first and but absolutely also working
across industry to ensure we've got
enough resources and enough experts to
do the work
and the reason we need that national
prioritization is otherwise everybody is
competing for the same pool of
scaffolders of cherry pickers of of
experts and actually it drives up cost
but it means we're not tackling those
buildings that are most at risk
first and i also agree with bob that
these costs
should not fall on residents whether
they are renters
whether they're leaseholders but i also
don't think that they should fall
on not-for-profit charitable housing
associations
the government has produced some funding
we have an acm cladding fund which has
been
hugely important and the sector the
social housing sector
is really um you know working very very
hard on the acm remediation of tall
buildings
we have a new building safety fund but
actually housing associations unless
they are claiming for the leasehold
apart
are not eligible for that fund so
there's not a level playing field with
that
um and i think um as bob said the
money's not going out fast enough but
actually the demand for that fund when
we when we see the outcome of it i think
is going to be far higher than the
amount that's available and so
we also need to think about long-term
financial solutions
to ensure that the work happens quickly
uh that it's prioritized but also that
those costs and those burdens do not
fall on residents whether they're
renters or leaseholders
john i think this is a question for you
uh and it is is house design the most
important thing to consider when looking
to build
new properties and this has been a
definite shift uh
in recent years you had nick bowles when
he was housing minister saying that the
reason people were so opposed to new
housing developments was that we were
building ugly rubbish
and then this government obviously had
the late roger scrutin to a whole
commission on architecture on building
beautiful
in the belief that if you built
tree-lined streets with attractive
properties
more people would become like you yimbys
rather than nimbys
do you think do you think design is the
most important thing to consider
well i'm sure bob will be the first to
tell you that
design is not the only thing that gets
people concerned about new development
and certainly bad design doesn't help
and there's no reason why
anybody should have to have bad design
but there are a whole range of other
things that people get concerned about
they get concerned about parking
traffic noise um congestion of local
health services you know so these these
are all of the things we need to address
um if we're going to solve the problem
of opposition to new housing and the
white paper tries to do that
bob uh do you i mean how do you feel
about this
it does feel um something slightly out
of revolutionary france a kind of
state-designed approved
set of beautiful buildings to be
designed i mean
where are you on this question does your
market soul reject it or not
no no far from it i i welcome uh the
provision
of tree-lined streets with two-story
housing
the reality is that a lot of the
proposals in the white paper
are not going to lead to that they're
going to lead to high-rise
uh high-density blocks of flats
without proper garden space for children
to play in
and without people being able to to
actually enjoy
the benefits of of of their homes and
that's my
my principal concern with with currently
with the
housing white paper uh i mean just give
you a quite an example
um two examples that i think are very
important here
um we've got the oxford cambridge
corridor which
is purportedly going to take a million
new homes
over an extended period of time and all
sorts of proposals being put on that
should we have a
a network of villages or new towns along
there
or should it be one conglomerate um
development
all the way along for for all that
distance and the other is what's going
on in london right now
what's going on in the suburbs in london
is every development
is big 20 30
40 stories of of housing
which frankly i've yet to meet anyone
who actually wants to live in these
places
they may be forced to live in them
because there's nowhere else but they
would certainly
not exercise that as a choice and i
think it's choice in housing
that we're going to have to get used to
and i i agree with john one of the
problems in
in all this development is we get
incremental development
so it's well this isn't quite enough to
justify a new school
it isn't quite enough to justify new
medical facilities
uh on by the way what we're gonna do is
cramp it down so there's no parking
available and what goes on in the
suburbs in particular
is that uh people still own cars they
just park them in residential streets
and overload those residential streets
so i think we've
we actually have to get some common
sense in this whole basis
and that's why it's important to consult
local people
and get their buy-in before development
takes place
uh on any planning application and do
you think do you think this has got i
mean
in government ministers would say that
the link up between school
provisions schools and hospitals and
housing has got better in recent years
is that your experience
uh no i mean i think that the reality is
that
if you're building a brand new estate
with
hundreds of new homes then that will get
planned into it
without doubt the big problem is that
generally speaking planning authorities
are dealing with
what i would call incremental growth so
that you'll get
an a block of flats or a a street of
homes
and it's not enough to justify certainly
not enough to justify a new school
and then suddenly you've allowed all
this development to take place and there
is no space for that new school
there is no space for that medical
center and i think that's
that's something that has to be taken
into account so local authorities
should be planning strategically for if
we're going to allow this type of
development
then we're going to need a new school or
expand existing schools
we're going to need a new medical center
we're going to need community facilities
we're going to need shops yeah you name
it we're going to need it
as opposed to just allowing the
development to proceed
willy-nilly right okay does bristol need
more pampers
i don't know if it needs more um pound
breeze
um but i think new communities should be
part of the solution
um i think that we need urban
regeneration i think we need growth
within
um our cities i think we we do need
growth within our suburbs but it should
be done with it
with except with good design and place
making and that does not always mean
building up
um you can do some fantastically high
density but
really really well designed communities
that are actually two
or three story high that there is access
to gardens it isn't always about about
the tower block and it is about
understanding how people want to live
and how they're going to want to live
as their families grow and change um
but saying that i do think new
communities are going to be part of the
solution we have
uh as as bob said we need to build 300
000 homes a year
roughly 100 000 of those to be social
and we can't
do that within the confines of our
existing cities and towns and so
it's about finding those those those
sustainable locations where you've got
transport
links where you've got um the ability to
plan in and build
you know opportunities for for work for
school for health all of those things
and doing that really really well
but not as bob says doing everything in
kind of piecemeal add-on
bolt-on estate baltimore state that
never quite kind of gets you the
infrastructure that you need to get
people to
to feel part of a community so um it is
actually about more planning not less
planning but
uh and and whether it's pound-free or
not um
you know if a community decides that
that's the aesthetic they want to go for
why not
but actually there's loads of other
creative ways of designing
places and i think um i like the word
beauty i think we should be talking
about beautiful places but it isn't just
about aesthetic
uh so we've got a question here from
grace she says why don't we lift the new
eviction rule that will this will limit
mass homelessness
bob you've done a lot of work on
homelessness and getting rough sleepers
into permanent accommodation and
moving towards a kind of housing first
strategy yeah do you think that's right
that lifting this no eviction rule would
limit mass homelessness
i well i think one of the things you can
say is the government did a brilliant
job
um over the pandemic to take literally
15 000 people
off the streets and put them into
accommodation
on a temporary basis i have been arguing
uh with ministers
about what we do going forward because
obviously
those people are gonna come back out of
that temporary accommodation
and they desperately need somewhere to
live by definition
they didn't have anywhere to live to
start with so with that that set of
people
who have to be uh provided with a
suitable
home as fast as possible the other issue
is of course
the uh moratorium we had on evictions
during the pandemic
now there was justification for this but
my big concern well i have a number of
concerns
but the biggest concern is that in this
country the private sector has been
required almost to take over what the
social sector
used to do and that is provide housing
for people that don't have it
um equally i that the figures are
something like 90
90 odd percent of private rented sector
homes are owned by people that own one
or two properties
they depend on that income from their
rent for those properties
and equally the most uh the
tenancies generally are six-month
assured short-haul tenancies
so we're in the position now whereby
since march
we've got to a position whereby
virtually every tenancy
in this country has expired
at which point what does the landlord do
if the
what we will lead to at the moment is a
position where by the landlord if they
issue a tenancy
we'll also issue a six-month notice to
to quit
because the government is requiring them
to um to basically to give six months
notice
so they renew the tenancy and give them
six months notice to quit
and the big problem as i see it is the
number of people
who are renting properties who basically
have decided
i don't need to pay my rent because you
can't evict me
and a large number of private sector uh
owners now are struggling because
tenants are just refusing
to pay their rent and and of course the
government said you can't evict them
now we've got re removed the moratorium
on on evictions
and i think for the most egregious cases
that's absolutely right
so the people that suff have caused
anti-social behavior
domestic violence or otherwise make the
broken the tenancy agreement
are prioritized but it is still an
absolute nightmare for a private sector
landlord
to get an eviction particularly on the
grounds of rentaries
and i think it's a real problem that the
government has stood up and by the way
i have been saying this to ministers
ever since this started
that we need a plan for what we do and
it's no good coming to the
crisis that we did uh the august bank
holiday weekend
when the moratorium was coming to an end
the ministers just
extended that moratorium for a month
that was not that's not a plan that's
that's dealing with a crisis and
papering it over what we have to have is
a long-term plan
for for what we do with the private
rented sector and the reality is the the
other issue that i've
i've highlighted is that those people
that are on
housing benefit or universal credit
should have their rent
paid direct to the landlords which would
then at least
reduce the uh the impact of rent arrears
that they're
uh suffering from and make sure that the
landlords were getting at least
an income stream probably wouldn't be
complete as kate said
it probably only covers part of the rent
but at least
the rent arrears would be reduced um and
and then we have to
we have to get back to the position of
saying look the courts have a process
um the other issue which i i know take a
bit of time here james but you are
a very complex question here um the
other issue is
that as things stood in the summer
if a case came in front of a judge and
someone owed more than eight weeks rent
then the judge had no choice whatsoever
but to
award a possession order to the landlord
which would mean that the tenant was
going to be out on their their ears
now these cases have to be looked at
individually
because some people have literally had
no income
since march when the when the lockdown
started particularly if they changed
jobs
particularly if they were self-employed
they weren't getting the support and the
issue then is were they getting any
money towards their rent or not
in which case the government has to look
at this in in
in the round on these people there are
others that quite frankly just
played the system and refused to pay
their rent well i have no sympathy
for those people whatsoever they they've
had the money
they've had the funding and they should
have paid their rent in which case
they should suffer the consequences
through the courts of not paying their
rent
but that's a you know individual
judgments have to be made on this
but we are on the we are on course at
the moment
for a major problem because there's
about the estimates are 350 000 people
are in rent arrears right now and
potentially could be
evicted when the moratorium completely
ends
well if baron estrada was on this panel
one of the architects of universal
credit
she would say that it but it's it's a
feature not a bug in universal credit
but the rent is not paid directly to a
landlord
her argument would be that you know in
the same way that owner occupiers
pay their mortgage out of their salary
you should be helping people to learn
how to budget by having them
pay their landlord for their rent rather
than the state doing so directly
what would you say to that argument no
yeah i think the design of universal
credit was absolutely right it is to get
people
to take personal responsibility for the
lives that they lead
um many of the people that are on on
universal credit particularly the people
that are
uh have been homeless have led chaotic
lives and therefore
need to understand what it's like to
receive a salary
and manage their money which is is
absolutely right
however we have a pandemic the like of
which we've never seen in our lifetimes
and i do think that there's a problem
here under normal circumstances
i would say no pay the money to to the
the tenant
they must then exercise uh their duty
and that is to pay their rent
and manage their finances we're in a
position whereby
a lot of people have reached the stage
of saying i can't manage my finances
um and should i pay my rent or should i
pay
should i buy food for the kids this is
the real problem here
that people are in a position whereby
they cannot manage
and so i would say look in this these
circumstances
and for a limited period of time then
that money should automatically go
to the landlord to at least safeguard
their
their housing because we pay i mean the
taxpayer is paying this money for the
rent
and therefore the rent must go to to the
landlord and if it doesn't
then uh we are potentially risking the
people that are
uh investing in property and letting it
out uh which will be a complete disaster
because many of those people
have chosen that route to supplement
their pensions
and therefore they're suffering from not
getting the money that they're due
so i think this is a i i understand
completely
the design i i it's one i support
strongly but i do
think that in these particular
circumstances we have to take stringent
action
okay where do you stand on this
evictions question so
so i think um bob's really clearly um
illustrated the difference between
private renting and social renting so in
terms of the
um evictions uh ban we welcomed that
and as a sector we made an absolute
commitment that
ahead of the evictions ban coming in in
about six months ago
but made an absolute commitment that
that no resident would be evicted
um due to the pandemic causing them to
be inventories
and we've worked incredibly closely our
members with their residents
in terms of hardship funds supporting
residents to access the welfare that
they're entitled to in helping
them navigate that system uh in tribute
to dwp
and they have had a tremendous amount of
pressure on them over the last six
months
they have um processed millions of
claims and they've worked really closely
with the sector
they've also done a couple of of things
um that have really helped support
residents so an additional 20 pounds
um which does go towards food uh has
been vitally welcome in terms of the
universal credit allowance during this
time
um but they've also made changes to the
payment system
so there's a new and improved payment
system for social landlords where you
can have a direct payment
to the landlord of the housing benefit
of the universal credit housing
benefit portion of of that and that's
really helped us sustain tendencies it's
helped support
uh it's being rolled out at the moment
but it's helping support those social
residents
manage their income and protect their
livelihoods and sustain their tenancies
it is very very different to the private
rented sector
um and i think it just kind of
illustrates how they are quite different
things so the private rented sector is
being used as a safety net for people
who'd be so much better off in
in social rent that they would get that
support and i absolutely hear what bob's
saying around those those private sector
landlords
many of which have have one home and
it's their income too
and now in a very tricky position so
there needs to be rental rights you know
rent
protection for those renters but that
also needs to be protection for those
landlords
but it's very very different in the
social housing sector just also on the
evictions
um we whilst we did support the ban
we've also supported it being
lifted um and that is because of the
points that bob raised as well the
evictions are a last resort but when
you're in
lockdown and somebody is doing
anti-social behavior
and it's affecting you in your home your
community it's it's horrendous
and there needs to be a tool to be able
to prevent that um and similarly with
with domestic violence there has got to
be
a mechanism for getting a perpetrator
out of her home um but that is
exceptional circumstances for us
and our sector is not using it for for
rental reasons
uh john uh we've got a question here
about the rent in london becoming
unaffordable for young people i mean
that comes back to the point you were
making
right at the beginning about regional
inequality and what the planning system
can do
to address that what you know the
government talks all about leveling up
how do you see that interaction between
leveling up and planning what are the
steps that need to be taken
to um to to begin to reduce some of the
house price discrepancy between the
various regions of the country
well the typical um home in london
has a price which is probably something
like four times
what it would actually cost to build
that home
now there are a number of factors in
that but the biggest factor by far
is the difficulty of finding land that
you're allowed to build more homes on
and so over time with a better planning
system
we could get rents in london to a much
more affordable level which would
reduce the the amount of housing need
which was then met by people by people
doing valuable jobs like kate
with that and that increase in supply
and the market supply can be done
without costing the government a penny
in fact
it will boost government revenues
because one of the ways to pay
for this very expensive support that we
as a society have deemed that we should
provide
to tenants um and other people is growth
and we have this literally this low
hanging fruit right there where we could
literally boost
growth by two percentage points a year
for a decade
by fixing planning and paying therefore
for all of the expensive things we've
been doing
and how does that affect inequality well
if you
if you let homes in london be built
when the south east be built um so that
over time they become more affordable
that will start to level out the
discrepancies across the country
it will also let people move around more
freely so a young person growing up
in the countryside can move to that job
in leeds that they want
or that job in manchester or birmingham
um because it's the shortage of housing
which is the biggest driver of that
inequality
what do you say to the question i think
is this
how do you get sufficiently uh
extra housing in london and the south
east without
uh building upwards in the way that bob
was talking bob was worried about you
know the
way that basically destroys the
character of these neighborhoods
so for us the the most popular
thing we've come across is if you show
people
type types of housing that they've seen
in the past whether they be terraced
houses
or perhaps mansion blocks so think of
bath
or um or edinburgh or
all over the country you'll see
traditional types of housing and they
don't have to be a traditional design
you can have a perfectly
a contemporary street that's still
walkable and people are happy to live in
it
um those are the sorts of things that
people are very happy to accept and so
that's why we think if we're going to
add more homes
and if you don't want to touch more of
the countryside the easiest way to do
that is to find ways that local
residents can live with adding
more of the types of things they're used
to townhouses and mansion blocks
that don't stick up into the skyline
which is not to say by the way i mean i
was talking with the housing campaign
yesterday who was very happy in the her
flat in the new 30 story
30 story tower she just moved into so i
mean there are people who want to live
like that
but um local people can get upset so
that the easiest way to do therefore
is to just is to add more density
in ways that everyone is already used to
do you think
that this realistically um can this be
done without
building on bits of a green belt it
would be possible to completely end the
housing crisis
without building on the green belt
whether we will or not is an entirely
different question but you could add
you could easily add five million homes
in london alone
without touching a square inch of the
green belt now whether we can solve the
political difficulties whether we have
the will to do that is an entirely
different question
right but because it does strike me that
whenever i hear these plans if you're
not going to even build on the green
belt near commuter rail stations for
example
it's straight i mean that doesn't
suggest you've necessarily got the kind
of political will
to build anywhere near the kind of five
million houses that you're talking about
in london in the southeast
so we suggested um in 2017 a reform to
let
parishes decide to allow housing uh
well-designed housing they liked on
their own green belt and the government
adopted that in 2018 under constraints
there are a long list of parishes that
would be delighted to add more housing
on their own green belt
um it's provided it's well designed it
meets local needs and they're being
stopped
by various layers of policy above that
so if we want to build on the green belt
the easiest and low hanging fruit way to
do it
is to let them go forward with it
yeah okay um kate we've got a question
here for you from
joe uh which probably will um
plunge fear into everyone who lives in
london um
can we build downwards is the question
i'm not sure i'm best equipped to answer
that question um
in terms of building downwards i think
it comes back to how people want to live
so do people want to have daylight and i
this isn't a
technical response it's just a human one
i can't imagine living somewhere where i
don't have access to natural light
and um i think everybody kind of needs
that for their well-being so
i think there might be some
opportunities to go down and certainly
opportunities to go up but it's about
good place making
livable homes and that's what beauty is
for me actually a beautiful home
it's somewhere that's accessible it's
affordable to heat um
you know it's got enough space it's got
you know to do homework for the kids the
kids
you know have bedrooms but it's it's
it's actually the fundamentals of kind
of good design
and in terms of yes space and quality
and being
being part of a community where you've
got kind of access to the things that
you need being able to walk to the pub
or to go out for a bike to eat being
able to pop out
you know walk to get a pint of milk
those kind of basics i think is what
beauty is in terms of place not just
statics but in terms of going down i
don't know uh if that's the right
solution for us
and what where where do you stand on the
question of
how many of you obviously represent
people in social housing
do you think that the the whole vision
of the kind of property owning democracy
the ultimate you know the classic tory
that's right mcmillanite view
but the ultimate aspiration is home
ownership do you do you think that is
now outdated or do you think that is
still you know what what most of tenants
in social housing would
if their financial circumstances improve
would like to do
so i think for um a significant
a vast proportion of the population
people would love to live in their own
home
and they'd love to run their home with a
bit of outdoor space um
and they'd like it to be in an area
where they had access to work into
schools
and um but i think the reality
is it's just really really really far
out of reach for millions of people
and so what we need to do is ensure that
everybody is well housed whether they
are social renting private rented or in
some form of the housing matter but we
have a
huge huge need for social housing as
part of that
um just because you're you're in social
housing doesn't mean that you can't move
out of it either so i think as a sector
yes
um we support the building of social
homes but we also are really positive
about home ownership as well it's
absolutely not
an either rule we need all of it but
it's in terms of the government
conversation it's where they direct
investment but also where they direct
investment right now in the midst of a
pandemic and a recovery
um because actually that building of
private homes at the moment is going to
be far harder in tougher economic
circumstances
and you're subject to mortgage
availability and everything else that's
going on in the economy
whereas we know there's absolute demand
for social housing
and that we know that if we invest in
that we can sustain those jobs we can
sustain the supply chains but also
there's just a huge huge need for that
type of home uh john where do you stand
up kate was talking about mortgage
availability there
there is currently a kind of policy
debate which is you know post 2008
there was a massive tightening up on the
criteria for getting a mortgage uh
that again banks are once more kind of
reluctant to lend because they're kind
of keen to preserve their capital in the
current circumstance
there is a push now politically uh
for a kind of return to kind of five
percent mortgages
uh for just five percent deposit
required and the argument is that that
would help more people get onto a
housing ladder
that would stimulate more uh more
construction and the like
where do you stand on that question
so i think there are clearly people who
are sufficiently credit worthy that they
can
um they can they can be relied upon to
repay a mortgage even if they only have
a five percent deposit
um but i think to a certain extent we're
just rearranging deck chairs on the
titanic here
you know there is no need for this
artificial limit on the number of homes
that we're trying to dole
out and of course the the problem of
affordability and homeownership varies
around the country so there are some
parts
especially outside the southeast where
owning your home is much more affordable
than it is in say oxford or london
and that proves that we could do so much
better
if we tried and um
okay you if you could do
one so your one policy would be the kind
of direct commissioning of more
social housing i think
now yeah if i had to pick one thing it
would be direct
investment in grant rates for social
social housing and i think
right now given where we are in terms of
economic uncertainty
having um a a sustained
high level of investment in social rent
would enable large construction sites to
keep going it would enable
us as a sector to withstand the risk of
a turbulent market cycle so
as bob said also um we had a real
reduction in funding for social housing
from 2010 onwards we have have some
funding now but we've been much more
um we've been building homes for sale as
well as the sector to cross subsidize
our affordable programs
and that becomes impossible in the
downturn there isn't that cross subsidy
so
our one ask would be yeah investment in
social rent
from grant and john
sketch out to me here the kind of
planning system that you
envisage well is it a kind of zonal
system
where uh as in the white paper where in
certain places you know
any development that that is in in line
with the the aesthetic of the area
um would get automatic permission to be
built is that what is that what kind of
system you think you need
to solve a problem so there's no doubt
having more certainty in the system what
everyone can know what's going to happen
and what's allowed would be better
but a zonal system doesn't necessarily
get you all the way so you still have
the question of
what you're going to zone and where 40
of the buildings in manhattan you
couldn't build today because the current
zoning will prohibit it
so you've still got this question of
what you're going to allow
for me um you you published a piece on
the spectator website a month ago it
should have outlined this idea of if you
gave
local control to residents on very small
scales a single street
or a single block and they can work out
for themselves what designs are
acceptable what they can all live with
and they can allow gradual addition of
density over time
that's a much more sustainable way of
supplementing what's coming through in
the existing system in a way that local
people are actually happy with
and you can add enormous volumes of
housing that way where it's most needed
brilliant well all that is now left me
to do is to thank uh our speakers today
uh to thank bob uh kate and john it's
been an
absolutely fascinating discussion and to
thank you all for your questions it's um
slightly odd not to be able to look at
you to say thank you but
thank you anyway um there are plenty
more events
to come in the spectators alternative
conference so this lunch time we're
having a live recording of
coffeehouse shots and this afternoon
we're having an event on
uh the best way to get to net zero so
hope to see you
back for some more of those events but
um uh i would normally say if you give
our speakers a round of applause but um
i i i i shan't uh seeing as
uh not sure david hee but um just
express your thanks to our speakers
and thank you all so much for tuning in
good night